[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
faye béton
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui on va passer une très belle
journée à vous et aux heures et aux
heures qu'est ce que c'est le désert
vous avez quel est le point commun entre
vous et le désert cdc si vous avez plus
de 100 de trouver un mec dans le désert
qu'un neurone dans votre cerveau c'est
pour ça que vous m merci cher c'est
gratuit ces chefs
sachez que tozeur c'est une ville qui a
une signification particulière pour moi
parce que c'est à tozeur a été créé la
marque à l'origine c'était dans les
années 16 112,14 étaient froids de frein
mais nous dit decrescendo c'est là alors
c'est sûr mais c'est la chance d'henri
iv
donc après celle du 13 enfin connaître
les chéris on va séparer motards janvier
gilles vous allez partir tout de suite
voir un cousin de valérie bénaïm et
c'est la nla d'arc à un super vous allez
être dans le réacteur de l'adar cas des
autres
une très bonne nouvelle vous allez
partir avec baba dans le désert on
partira à 8
on viendra certainement à tour
ressentent dans le désert filet on vous
suit igeho fiche oui
les manceaux
là où il dit moi aussi
[Musique]
m
dedans
ne me dis pas qu'on va avancer sur les
dunes
i'm an des poissons et qu est-ce qu on
arrive
j'adore
[Musique]
ans
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
leur père
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non non non elle en silence
[Musique]
à
divali les choix
[Musique]
il
oui
je
[Applaudissements]